hey guys welcome back to brand-new River
back on Monster a roll again today we
have some new interesting info about the
new upcoming monster coming somewhere in
the summer for monster on the world that
being B Hamas or behemoth whatever you
want to call him he's part of the Final
Fantasy 14 and the monster owner world
collaboration like I said coming in the
summer a little bit of more info some
from a press release or anything like
that regarding some of the developers on
Monster Hunter world so with that like
the view if you do enjoy subscribe
before new I cover the solo guides of
most the monsters in monster honor world
as well as the weekly event quests and
more tips and tricks to make everyone a
better monster on the player and with
that let's get started with today's
video so the first thing that they
wanted to tackle was the gameplay and
this is probably one of the harder
things because they wanted to make sure
it still has the Final Fantasy elements
with the monster owner world elements
together and not going too far into one
specific category as I said they wanted
to make the monster very different than
the existing monsters in Monster Hunter
world but still also wanted to maintain
the integrity of a Final Fantasy type
character one of the developers I
believe tsujimoto is his name he says
that behemoth is very unique something
that you've never seen and in previous
battles or anything previously a monster
hundred before they'll definitely have a
very good strategy going into battle
they also said behemoth is going to be
any large monster range not super super
big as big as cool to Roth probably loop
it's smaller than that but there will be
a specific area designed it just for
this boss fight which is also really
nice and apparently this fight is also
going to be very aggressive so don't
expect a drawn-out pacify it like Lau
Shang lung which is pretty interesting
as well there was no information about
the kacct war which is kind of sad
because that was one of the more
important things I wanted to hear about
regarding this collaboration and they've
also put in a bunch of Easter eggs for
people to notice that our fans of the
Final Fantasy series that they will
definitely enjoy when they see them as
well as a few music tracks from some of
the previous Monster Hunter games or
Final Fantasy games to kind of throw
into the battle which is also really
nice and regarding future collaborations
Yoshida and tsujimoto said that there
are no plans for the moment but for good
reason if we feel that we have the next
time we might hold back Yoshida added
that because they never considered they
have a next time
they're concentrating and focusing on
what they have now and going in with as
much effort as possible but yeah I guess
just a quick recap of the video that
basically means behemoth is going to be
a pretty big monster also very
aggressive he's not going to be as cool
as big as cool to Roth and he's not
going to be a passive fighter like
allowing lung from the
via schemes of monster honor I don't
member exactly what monster that is
seeing as brawled as my first Monster
Hunter game but still he's like I said
he's going to be very aggressive and
still a big monster in terms of size and
the fact that they're going to be
dedicating a whole new specific zone
just for this plate just as cool to Roth
head which is also very nice to hear so
yeah let me know what you guys think in
the comments below I really looked into
her thoughts a really cool information
not too much I thought I was expecting a
little bit more but still it's really
cool that we did get some decent
information about this what that guy's
it's going to be the end of it today I'd
like to be if you do enjoy subscribe for
new like I said a couple of the solar
guys for most of the monsters and
Monster Hunter world and I'll definitely
be covering a guide on behemoth once he
releases in the summer there is no like
I said specific date but whenever he
happens to released I'll do a guide on
him as well as the tips and tricks to
make everyone a better monster on her
player and the weekly event quest so
that everyone can be up to date on what
to do
how did defeat those certain quests and
all that good stuff so with that guys my
two most recent videos will be on screen
hope you guys enjoyed the video and
peace out